hello and welcome to omixlogic in this
video we will go over the data science
training program further and look into
how you can use various resources to
deepen your understanding of biomedical
data analysis visualization and
integration using machine learning
some of the highest paying jobs and
interesting ones are for data scientists
who can extract meaningful insights from
biological data
in other words you can take your
understanding of the biological
processes and apply it to novel drug
discovery
diagnostic methods maybe improvement on
different processes and so as scientists
are looking deeper into these biological
processes they are requiring
computational analysis skills to extract
signal that is relevant to the type of
question that they're trying to ask and
so in this program we want to take some
examples of such projects and illustrate
how machine learning and data science
can be used to address some of those
questions some of the projects are going
to be around diagnostics and cancer
biology other ones will focus on single
cell and tissue compositions and other
ones we'll talk about the microbiome and
infection now all of these datasets are
sourced from the national center for
biotechnology information that layers
this information from extracting
knowledge all the way to the raw data
the knowledge really represents the
important findings that researchers have
already found but it relies on a body of
evidence and that evidence contains raw
data so taking the raw data including
over
15 petabytes of raw data from sequencing
we're going to look at how to use that
kind of data and actually see what are
the specific patterns what are specific
relationships and different types of
biologically interpretable signals that
we can find we also have about a hundred
thousand of public data sets of gene
expression omnibus in other words
process structure tables of gene
expression levels and we have over six
million annotated genomes that means we
have a lot of information of where did
this
information come from and how to map it
to some kind of biological function
now the data the raw data that we're
going to be talking about can include
many different types of omics data that
can include
phenotypic information which is
typically annotated in some kind of a
structured format but also comes from
raw data sometimes images or clinical
information includes genomic data that
can contain variation at the dna level
individual mutations or frequencies of
mutations we'll look at epigenomic data
which can include dna methylation and
histone modification and a lot of it
will be about transcriptomic data which
is expression levels of genes isoforms
of those genes or transcripts including
exons introns and other things so when
we look at all of these different types
of omits data for all of them you have
to understand the specific ways that
this data can be prepared for analysis
to be able to
ask questions find associations between
phenotype and genotype or the molecular
features associated with clinical or
biological conditions and how you can
then use this information so what does
this information mean what does the link
mean what is the specific feature
associated with a condition mean how do
we actually use it so that's what this
program is going to be all about we'll
try to cover some of the analytical
methods that are useful for processing
visualization and analysis of complex
biomedical data we'll talk about the
terminology of machine learning and
artificial intelligence in biomedical
discovery and then we'll also talk about
some of the project examples where you
can see how machine learning was used
effectively to achieve meaningful
results
as a result of going through this
program you will be aware of the data
wrangling and exploratory data analysis
in this kind of data you'll see the
overview of different types of
statistical methods and machine learning
approaches according to the application
that you would like to use them for
you'll see different types of coding
environments including r and python but
also different tools to facilitate the
exploratory analysis to make it
reproducible and then once you look at
these case studies and different types
of omics data you'll understand how some
of the steps are going to be exactly the
same depending on what data it's going
to be the same initial steps and some
are going to be specific so in other
words you have to link biology with
the data side of things
so that's why this specific data science
training program is really to help you
understand various types of omics data
learn about exploratory data analysis
and the steps for processing data and
preparing it for machine learning
try some of the big data analysis tools
for large-scale project data and try
machine learning models in the context
of biological discovery and then look at
the link between biology and data and
master biological interpretation so
let's look at the syllabus the syllabus
is organized into three different parts
there's going to be a part that is
dedicated to introduction a second part
that's dedicated to a review of methods
the first part is going to kind of give
you a crash course on terminology and
key concepts both in biology in omics
and in the specific types of machine
learning methods and methods for data
preparation then we'll talk take a look
at the methods themselves what do they
actually do how do they work what do
they mean and what kinds of assumptions
do they have about the data that they
use including some of the settings
inputs and outputs that we're going to
be looking at
and then how are these methods actually
applied and used so what are some case
studies what are some examples that we
can learn from to see the limitations as
well as the opportunities for machine
learning for this kind of data we'll
look at examples with a large number of
samples and a small number of samples
with high variability or very controlled
experimentation so we'll look at all
those kinds of variables and try to link
it all together into a satisfying
experience now the typical way that we
do these programs is we combine
interactive sessions with self-guided
study materials what that means is that
you can join the session and kind of
gain an overview of a particular topic
but if you really want to go deeper than
that if you want to study and learn and
understand it on your own you will have
to do the work in between the sessions
so going to those practical steps will
help you gain the most out of these
interactive sessions so let's take a
look at some of these topics and try to
go into a little bit more detail about
what each one of these will cover
so the first part is we're going to do
an introduction so the introduction is
intended for those that don't quite know
what this means maybe you have some
questions what do these terms mean what
is genomic data and how is it different
from transcriptomic data what are we
studying when we have metagenomic
sequencing data maybe you don't know
exactly what does raw sequencing data
really look like or maybe you don't know
what is the difference between
clustering and random forest so those
are the topics that we will try to
address in the first part of this
program
then we're going to go into the
different categories of machine learning
what are they and how are they used how
do you use it to
explore and understand data structures
using unsupervised machine learning how
do you train a model and what kinds of
models are there with what kinds of
assumptions that then you can use for
classification or regression and then
we'll also talk about feature selection
and gene signature construction as an
example of biomarker discovery or
specific types of patterns that really
help understand the model and understand
the accuracy and reproducibility of the
results in a particular training data
set that overcomes the overfitting and
helps us understand the generalizable
principles of a particular
model of how the model is trained and
how it learns
so then we'll talk about
regression and generalized linear models
network analysis deep learning how to
combine different methods together and
we'll talk about it both from a use case
perspective so
in what sense is network analysis useful
for time series data how is it useful
for one sample when we talk about
biological interpretation we'll talk
about how generalized linear models are
used for actually processing data and
give us accurate results from this
complexity of sequencing and how can
deep learning be used to improve
accuracy and decrease feature
engineering that a lot of conventional
machine learning relies on after that is
done we will start talking about
projects and these projects could be
clinical or they could have an industry
perspective so obviously they could also
have a basic research example as well
and so what are some of the project
examples that we've prepared we have
cancer macrophages different types of
endemic or pandemic
outbreaks that we will look at in terms
of the data and how that data can teach
us about the specific outbreak or the
virus that we're looking at we'll take a
look at modeling cancer precision
medicine how we can identify specific
biomarkers types of patients as well as
their response to treatments we look at
the complexity of tumor growth and micro
environments and we'll also touch on
some of the other projects that you can
find relative to biotechnology
agrobiology and environmental sciences
but overall you will see the full
process of going from experimental
design understanding what the
researchers were trying to do when they
generated data to then processing that
data and preparing it for analysis
understanding the patterns understanding
whether it fits the assumptions that you
have about the data
to then statistical in-depth analysis or
mathematical modeling as well as machine
learning so that you can manipulate the
data in such a way that it answers a
particular question and what that
question is and how it can give you
results that you can infer some meaning
from you can generalize you can
understand you can actually find
something useful in that data at the end
of all of these different sessions
you will get a certificate of completion
so the certificate of completion will be
under your profile
and to make sure that your profile is
ready for that you have to have your
full name you have to have a brief
description of your
background which you can add under your
profile on the learn omixlogic.com
portal on one side you will have the big
data analysis platform we'll introduce
you to a lot of the methods very quickly
on the other side you will have the
omics logic portal there you will find
all the training materials and the
resources that you need now in terms of
this introduction to machine learning
the portal has a specific collection of
courses these courses are organized by
topic and the ones you want to start
with are introduction to bioinformatics
and r and python bytes and molecules and
then bioml
now inside the training courses you will
have exercises which break down the
syntax of a code and they also take a
look at different examples with
testable results that means that
automatically you get feedback is this
the correct way to run it or incorrect
and you can also modify them
after you have learned and you have
understood how the different pieces of
the code work essentially your goal will
be to create a jupiter notebook you can
use google colab or install jupyter
notebooks on your computer and then
create a repository in github where you
have your process data
that is prepared as an example that
other people can find and reproduce your
results your code
in a
notebook that has both comments and the
code that is executable and that is
something that you can use to actually
show the outcome of what you have
learned in this program so i'm excited
to get started hope to see you all in
our next session